Nikki Haley's a US ambassador to the
United Nations she's with us from
midtown Manhattan in New York ambassador
Haley good morning good morning the
president said that the 2015 Iran
nuclear deal was quote one of the worst
and most one-sided transactions the
United States has ever entered into is
that a clear signal that he plans to
withdraw from the nuclear deal with Iran
it's not a clear signal that he plans to
withdraw what it is is a clear signal
that he's not happy with the deal and
that the United States is not safer
because of it I think if you look at the
fact that yes on one side it deals with
the nuclear development the jcpoa which
everyone talks about but US law requires
it to look at other things which Iran is
in violation of arm smuggling
making sure certify the deal and at the
same time pursue Iran on these other
aspects of their behavior well that's
the thing is that's what we have to do
whether it's through US law and other
things is to start exposing that Iranian
president rouhani said in his words that
leaving the agreement would come at high
cost what's your response to his
reaction well I think what he needs to
do is instead of focusing on us leaving
the agreement he needs to start
following the rules I mean he is he's
got to start smuggling stop smuggling
arms he's got to stop all of the
meddling that they're doing around the
Middle East their support of terrorism
we've got to see them stop with the most
ballistic missile testing so he is not
keeping his end of the deal we have to
keep it on him will the United States
not certify the deal the president has
to make that decision that's his
decision alone what I can tell you is if
he does not certify he's certainly on
grounds to not do that
ambassador let me turn to North Korea
and reduce some of the comments the
president made he said it's an outrage
that some nations would not only trade
with such a regime but would arms supply
and financially support a country that
imperils the world with nuclear conflict
is the president talking about China and
Russia and if so why did he not name
them specifically I think he was talking
to all countries you know we've got
countries in Africa that do trade with
North Korea we've got countries around
the globe that interact with North Korea
and what worse
this is a country who is threatening its
neighbors threatening the United States
continuing to use ballistic missile
testing but now also nuclear bombs that
they're testing and we have to stop
every ounce of funding that they use to
do bad things
ambassador did you know that the
president was going to refer to Kim
jong-un the president of North Korea's
rocket man and if so do you think that
that kind of language and that kind of
mocking is helpful but first did you
know he was going to use that
terminology I did I was aware that
morning that he was going to use it and
I will tell you just to let you know
what this does I had a meeting with the
President of Uganda the day before and
he was referring to Kim as Rocketman
before the president even gave the
speech under what circumstances what
specific circumstances with the United
States launched an attack against North
Korea we have lots of military options
so it's not just the destruction it's
there are steps that lead up to that
what I can tell you is no one wants war
the president doesn't want war we have
tried to do this through dialogue we
tried to do this through sanctions we've
tried every diplomatic measure that we
possibly can we're not giving up on that
we have said to Kim multiple times we
don't want regime change we don't want
war what we want you to do is stop
testing and start working on nuclear
production they have chosen not to do
that okay but the president has used
words like fire and fury before I mean
what do you believe is necessary to get
his attention well I think that's the
problem is no one knows how to get his
attention so all you can do is continue
to let him know what could happen if he
doesn't stop but I can tell you
everyone's trying to get his attention
Japan and South Korea are very grateful
to us
China has tried dialogue and that
relationship has broken down everyone is
trying to figure out how to get to Kim
that's the problem we just don't know
how ambassador hey thank you so much for
joining us this morning thank you so
much